smoke haddock and spinach baked eggs
smoked haddock one of my favorite fish
delicious
highly sustainable packed with protein
lightly smoked there's not a dye smoke
there's a big difference see i've got
that bright yellow tinge
so much better
next baby spinach
it's a spinach that's very young full of
zinc great flavor little teaspoon
volleyball knob of butter
that little touch of oil
stops the butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two thirds
i'm cooking spinach in butter
i open up the top of my peppermill so
the pepper becomes almost like sort of
cracked pepper lots of fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tarragon it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep hold of these and grateful when
you're making a tag and vinegar red wine
vinegar tag and stalks in
chop your tarragon into your creme
fraiche
a little seasoning
now
grain mustard goes brilliantly well with
havok
incredible
this mustardy herbie creme fresh will
work equally well partnered with grilled
chicken
the headache's starting to flake because
it's smoked lightly cured it cooks so
quickly your creme fraiche
it's nice
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you got this wonderful
egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
just a little twist of pepper
get the remainder of your cream fresh
and put a little dollop
in between that adds richness to the egg
whites
into the oven at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs bake
together i can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchen chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but i
love that nice dark green flavor it's
less harsh than the white
the smell of baked mustard you can't
beat
[Music]
that is beautiful
spinach was almost melted in with a hat
up now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
wow
my ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what i like to dunk in
it an anchovy soldier anchovies
interpersonal water no salt naturally
yeah anchovies are very salty so just a
touch of pepper
rich in omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavour enhancer
and i use it to pepper many a savory
dish from roast lamb to the humble
toasted soldier
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being at
the seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 percent anchovy 50
butter that way got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish i'm in heaven
the bread
this is a sourdough
delicious very crusty
take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil
the secret of softly boiling an egg is
to place them into the water gently on a
spoon
in
and just tilt so they don't hit the
bottom nice
and light
up to the boil count to five
turn the gas down
is it four and a half minutes is it five
minutes for a softball day i've cooked
thousands of them and every time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling
get your bread
and spread that on there that is
incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
inside but i can't resist
oh my god
right
gas off
one
beauty in
two
i feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
some of the best food i had in india was
street food and
every little food stall was cooking up
something spicy something delicious
a teaspoon
of oil gonna toast off
a teaspoon
of cumin
mustard seeds
a touch of salt
and pepper
lightly fry them off
it's really important to cook off the
spices it intensifies the flavor but
really draws out that nice spicy deep
rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind nice and fine
onions in
[Music]
now
we're gonna caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have
started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there
get it nice and sort of rich
gas up nice and high
and really caramelize those onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful
add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot
if you don't cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight
four nice eggs
now give those eggs
a little whisk a little touch
of butter
into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot add a
teaspoon of garam masala and turmeric
cook that out
now
take your eggs
into the pan
almost gonna make
like a really nice spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter
i quite like the sort of creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there
i get my spinach
chop up
and then fold in
the spinach
to your scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast but it's served in
these wonderful little
thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan take the eggs off the heat
whilst you get on with the last job add
quick mint and spice yogurt dressing
a couple of tablespoons
of fresh yogurt in
there's always something take out the
heat then add chopped mint
salt and turmeric
mix that in
now
take
a scrambled egg and half fill
and now
it smells incredible get your yogurt
down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food in india
how delicious they can make street food
with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
spicy mexican eggs
this is a very classic mexican style
brunch dish
bold kick-ass flavors slice the chili
seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
i'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch can see you
right through to dinner now to start the
sort of spicy fragrant tomato sauce get
your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
never embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes i do all the time cooking at
home
now by reducing that
you sort of come down to a delicious
paste
leave that to simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse some a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb
leaving the dense beans to luxuriate in
the spicy tomato sauce will allow them
to soften and soak up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven-proof dish
from my spicy egg brunch to baking
i'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
these are a staple in mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix
and place that on top of the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps i want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into there
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside
almost like it's a little dug dugout and
then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
montgomery cheddar i want to grate the
tortilla shell as well so get generous
with it on the top
and we'll season that with these little
babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg
just salt
a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for 8 to 10
minutes
and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
it's a little bit of coriander to finish
it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started
spicy mexican eggs and a crispy tortilla
shell